Erin gray good dank
dude
be back here
mr. white
well I think we should just start here
yes yes it seems like there's no there's
no real well never thought of a good
intro so it feels like I know just start
Vincent okay welcome dick SMS culture
pounding commentary and cobwebs in cape
suit crepe suzettes dang suit Craig
suits like a Craig teen else enough but
you like to tellin ya it's just like a
little big rubber suit that turns you
into Craig to Nelson now I dress up as
cranky now I'm gonna go down the
learning hospital you know surprise the
kids yeah wait learning husband true
learning hospital somewhere teaching
hospital teaching hospital yes as do you
learn you teach somebody you don't learn
something yeah that's a vocabulary I'm
gonna take a picture right now of both a
photograph yeah if you guys go on
Twitter when this is out just kind of
check it check out you know our little
photo here you're gonna look at this
photograph yeah who's Laurel Grail blue
I thought thing on the internet once
were didn't I did I thought flagrant
missa miss apprehension of the truth
something no no check it out though
there's so they're like 10 things at
least in the internet what um ya know
Charlie this is there's this whole ton
of [ __ ] on the internet but um something
I don't even remember i was gonna say
but but basically if you go on the
internet what did you say what did I
didn't say anything you said some [ __ ] I
would never say a thing well I've never
said anything in my life well anyway
it's really pleasant what would like
just this view right now just like cuz
we're recording it's hot in this garage
or we're recording right now I saw in
this studio yeah and there's just like a
nice view out the window here so we've
got a little fan we've got our computer
setup we have mint green houses across
the way yeah you know they're they're
nice you know metallic mint-green just
like in my cousin vinny and I'm so
there's some clouds out we've got a
couple bottles of a downtown brown so uh
lost coast brewery if you're listening
uh we're repping you or revenue and we
would love to be sponsored by your
fabulous product with this Quentin
Tarantino [ __ ] on the
he is his face is just misshapen enough
the man on the downtown brown bottle
boys you assume his name is downtown
brown ya know that is insane bro this
race is just misshapen enough to vaguely
represent their vaguely resemble Toronto
know Quintin torrentially know exactly
and what a better segue then to get into
the thing that we're talking about that
just was weird this is like that fastest
[ __ ] cigarette oh yeah cuz like you
you reference the thing we're going to
talk about like within the first 90
seconds and that's the vet speaks to the
real magic yeah of downtown brown and
maybe the real magic of the thing we're
going to talk about yeah yeah but before
I mean downtown Brown Commerce man I
mean if you're at your local liquor
store or even a grocery store I come to
town bronze like widely available
outside of California I whenever I come
to one of your birthdays I pick that
[ __ ] up at Gelson's yeah but or ralphs
but you you buy it at Gelson's and rouse
in California like well then this is not
Ralph's outside of California again to
its kroger yeah it's a Kroger store so
once you get a California rouse becomes
fred meyer all right the guy who did all
this video games for the pc said Sid
Mayo said said Meyer that's odd no like
I drove up to to this state that has
Portland in it whatever is called oh oh
Portlandia yeah I drove up from
California to Portlandia on my way to
see at alia and when we once we got over
the state line and we were in we were in
scarf sklar bro country school are
broken once we were in in Portland State
country there were no more else it was
Fred Meyer but are they the same or is
that just what they have instead like
ends like in a min New York hell yeah in
Portland State you can't pump your own
gas they have to pump it for you and we
were like oh what is fred meyer and
which is a ridiculous question I didn't
ask it my traveling companion asked what
is fred meyer which is like well clearly
it's the brand of this gas station why
would you ask such a flagrant question
and
the pump man the pump master the pump
Lord pump lord that sounds like a like a
like the name of a gaya in a porn parody
of mad Mac in the pump water hump Lord
or or like a guy with a really really
really pretentious bike shop ha the pump
look come on damn by faucet stars get a
free fill up on air pump lord I have my
jewel encrusted pump way and I'm super
pumped to pump you up hmm so really or
like as an absolutely [ __ ] absurd
self parodying like personal trainer
yeah you would see his flyers just like
on the corkboard at a coffee shop the
pump low or personal trading dietary
advice um no the pump lord at the fred
meyer gas station was like oh it's a
Kroger store like routes like you you
Californians have oh so they are the
same entity yeah they are both Kroger
stores yeah fred meyer and Ralph's are
both under the kroger brand banner of
brands and banners yeah it's like vons
and pavilions all lead back to safeway
right yeah bonds and pavilions all lead
back to kaiser soze ave man is the one
who gets away with no that's reload
tomorrow yeah i'ma go lo tomas yeah LA
confidential yeah wait Rollo Tomasi was
not confidential I thought it was a red
herring the usual suspects no Rollo
Tomasi well oh that's right that's right
yeah yah Rollo Tomasi I was thrown up
like Kevin Spacey being all of them and
then when Rollo Tomasi like he's the
left town to go back to k-pax yeah
that's exactly what happened there and
then Eric dude another but another segue
because you know i was in capex who at
the very end is aaron paul he is that's
right he's Jeff Bridges his son yeah who
we see for like a scene a moment with it
is drooling like a wide shot so there's
no actual dial in and of what seems to
be a train station the same translation
or whatever station train zone that that
prot or fruit prout yes prout I'm sorry
much apologies to prote wherever you are
and he's on capex I think he went that
thing really I feel like this is one of
those things words like it was
purposefully vague and so it's like
whenever something is purposefully vague
the world splits in half of people
saying it's definitely this thing or
it's definitely bad thing no Todd
definitely follows over-the-top
definitely doesn't fall over I'm like it
was supposed to be big well yeah saying
right I air more toward that side i'm
not saying like oh yeah it is sure it is
played kind of wistfully at the end of
that movie like it's like it's so much
wasteful of whist yo yeah it's all this
is just leaking out whisk that movie k
box I still like it I think but I
haven't seen it in an age i BES like
phone booth works like oh I really liked
it when I saw which was in 2002 no no
whose Twitter what I was twit don't tell
you don't even we want okay so we're
going to do a joke right now where it's
become an in-joke with us but it's based
on something of us like talking about
like we wants like hypothesizes what
like we I think we're hypothesizing what
would be like it if the Insane Clown
Posse did like an ad for educational
tapes to teach kids math it was like yo
so we got all the numbers like 14 11 and
ninety seven and twelve to go to Nobu
and we told y'all about swell and you
best not tell the way we we told y'all
about 12 he's really very like I lease
we're free versions of the ICP boys well
no like we had that growing up though
like we had in like second or third
grade our teachers would occasionally
bring in these they would make raps out
of the times table but the most dorkiest
non-functioning raps remember like the
rapping dinosaur that would teach kids
to recycle yeah yes oh I love it the
legate's there's no way that it's really
hard to design an educational
entertainment properly especially when
you try in the labor when you try like
later hip hop into the back when hip-hop
was just starting to go mainstream well
yeah it's like teaching anybody anything
is hard to begin with it especially if
their children and then
teaching anybody anything and then
adding like a music form and the visual
representation to that that's like
whimsical this that's that's have three
really hard place juggling too many
balls you spreading yourself too thin
too many people your other analogy
yourself yeah all right yeah we got to
k-pax and then we got to what was the
first segue we had to segue yo is Joe
hater actually wait and then we had
Quentin torrentially know we needed a
third segue before it's like compositing
the shrine of the silver monkey and
legends of the hidden temple you gotta
bring all dirty parts together to get it
to activate which like enough kids I was
wondered about that because like enough
kids had seen that show had like so many
times it would get confused and like
putting together wrong and I'm like the
head clearly goes on top likes well I
mean if memory serves it was a really
bright destroying at the silver monkey
so those kids were basically semi-blind
ok don't blind children for other
children's entertainer yeah I've never
blind a child for that purpose just
because you blind somebody doesn't mean
they can execute anything like blind
executive is not a not a term that
stretches that far and then there was a
blind executive gag in one episode oh
[ __ ] is that our 33rd segue will we
accept it let's we will see if we accept
it after a word from our sponsor Frank
ass tubs flag ass rubs spices marinades
for your next barbecue brought to you by
mr. Tubbs himself mr. Tubbs mr. T I'm
not not the original mr. t ya know but
he does pity fools who don't use the
proper bar frankest Tubbs is a very
empathetic man he feels really bad for
people who are foolish yeah i mean i
went i will actually went to his office
and he was looking out of his window
crying Oh buddy and I said Frank what's
wrong and he just sniffed and he turned
to me and his eyes were red and
bloodshot he just said all the foods all
the food all the fools out there
there's my to move a david sedaris essay
was talking about working at macy's
santillana apparently there's this he
describes his man who comes in who's
like oddly like just very excited but
he's like older and he can't really tell
where he's from he just knows he's easy
like from Eastern Europe or something
like he's not from here he keeps coming
in to sit on Santa's lap throughout the
day Oh God and at one point I guess he
asks him why and all the guy does at
least in this retelling is just go the
toilet all the toys to be a family which
is the what and like apparently he had
this like dent in his forehead or
something like like like 2d of the
gorillas yeah when people make moves to
do hey girls are gonna record again Oh
again in that navami oh really yeah
november i think they said our September
time that they're gonna go into the
studio intraday state that Damon over
man that that dude just has hella Tunes
in his mind yeah and in his brain and it
was hard yes oh [ __ ] taking up tweets
I'm sending its which you know we gotta
do we gotta do some kindness what
happens when you live tweet real life
while recording yourself in the real
life while you're live tweeting the real
life yeah it's like you're gonna create
this weird rift where it's like if you
read the tweets that we're tweeting
while we're recording this while you're
listening to the replay then it's
technically at the same time but they're
both in the past but they're also in the
present you're going to listen to the
thing you did to affect how the episode
turned out that you when and if the
future you when you which you want you
when you want you wish you want you want
you wish you did you want you want Ian
to do you so much to do anything exactly
has anyone ever thought to think to do
look more like has anyone been as far as
decided to go want to do even to look
more like ah absolutely I just love that
I love it when someone can compose a
sentence that makes absolutely no sense
it's my fav
but uh you know speaking of we need like
like one of those in app like like an
app where you follow along with the TV
show but for this pug like a second
screen experience a second screen
experience this is our fourth hour for a
segue yeah a little bit of a deeper cut
yeah but uh all right should we go for
fiber just call it for I mean for is
like we have extra credit weird any
inching right now yes it so hard yeah
we're in the red if any of those segways
were not enough we have like some
spillover to take care of a deficiency
yeah you know it's like whenever on the
news they're like hey vitamin D is good
for you and then everyone just like
stocks the [ __ ] up on vitamin D it
doesn't even think about what the proper
amount is yeah and as i well know
everyone's taking too much vitamin D so
I just shout it out to a lost coast
brewery again yeah hopefully they will
sponsor the show with John Brown yeah by
the way I saw Ruth yeah uh by the way
we're still not dead still not women
yeah we're still well we're not dead yet
because if anyone recalls um at the end
of our loan episode oh oh I'm sorry I
thought you were that was that was a
little hard I think we're talking about
the conversation from earlier oh yeah I
apologize that's it it's an in-joke for
another time yeah um no yeah we're still
not dead uh tarun spooky days um I think
you're giving us the silent treatment no
they'll call me up every now and again
it breathe very heavily that's [ __ ]
bad yeah except I i did for some reason
it doesn't sound like sinister breathing
like it's like sounds like a mire yeah
or just like you know like like tired
and kind of overweight like like maybe
uncle Janish is the guy phones is like
the this the operator at Terry's cookies
or something hey the operator call back
to a marble heart call back tomorrow
this this should be our clip show yes
this chick said there's too much
original content yes is true I
what are you doing I don't know i just
found this under on this twitter and i
don't know what it means but i'm very
happy it's here it's like a weird spooky
skeleton watching too many cooks who
hurt too many cooks yeah there's a lot
of there's a lot of good surrealist
insane comedy out there these days I do
appreciate that you know um I don't know
always get into like you know adult swim
is kind of a hit-and-miss network for me
but I do appreciate stuff like that like
too many cooks or that one that starts
out what is it uncut footage of a bear
or whatever by the same guy but it's
like it starts out as nature footage and
it becomes it breaks for commercial for
like an antidepressant except the
antidepressant commercial just goes so
far out of control that it's kind of
upsetting and and creepy but also funny
but also an unsettling and it's like
this woman has to take antidepressants
cuz it's a commercial but then it starts
ruining her life and like you know just
it's like this apocalyptic scenario all
of us or it's very strong there's um
apparently between you know like moral
orel the moral moral mortal oral it's
really moral orel there's like a big
pressing set with Adult Swim projects
especially if like in the past few years
versus like everything starts off is
goofy wacky zany edgy comedy and it like
veers off to specifically something you
didn't expect like moral orel went very
dark and very deep and very you know
dramatic I feel like maybe too many
cooks start like oh haha it's a parody
of like you know you know cheap old you
know bad sitcom stuff and then it just
went farm more insane that anyone could
have pretended and upsetting yeah I'm
weird one and I almost wonder especially
for the series fifth segue probably the
most sophisticated if that's like if
that's because they're either shows like
like Rick and Morty and even these
things on adult swim that you know like
moral orel and stuff that start out as
you know you know kind of fun and silly
and and you know sort of what you were
expecting
you know an animated sitcom or whatever
and then halfway through our part way
and start to get kind of deep and and
cerebral and and kind of affecting and
you know even sometimes jarring it's
like I wonder if that's just the in its
like people start or even Adventure Time
kind of does that yeah where it's like
big adventure time kind of weird it's
it's post-apocalyptic head yeah it's
like a while I wonder if they had to
basically be like no no this is a fun
thing haha I like to sell the show and
then once the show picks up there like
okay now let's spring the trap yeah it's
we've got six episodes all right now
let's start slowly creeping in some some
[ __ ] getting real yeah and you know
which other show does that a lot of our
topic tonight fifth segue a good time
yeah we're talking about Bojack horseman
Alex original dank Jack horses that's
the name of this episode currently
unless we decide to change it to bodega
BOGO dang horse stud so I just just look
out for that yeah yeah Bojack horseman
fortunate rootsman I talking about I
really love this show it we just do to
it launched its second season and we we
binge did hard you binge harder than I
did well I mean yeah I try I needed a
little more time to bend but I did binge
and I i binge didn't I perched and i
binge TN yeah my body is empty bad joke
well you know you just do for another
perk I guess yeah yeah well I mean it
comes once a year yeah like Christmas oh
hey oh the purge or the purge exactly
are ya bojo gonna Jack horseman um
season two Susan to see tues out season
one I just read an article to some one
of those critics basically put this
article of one like Huffington Post her
or something like that or maybe watching
the first ever know but it was basically
like hey sorry for that shitty review
from before cuz I was wrong yeah like
that I actually got to read that because
the thing is Bojack horseman got a very
middling reception um when it first
launched because it's a very serialized
show
and that first season basically it does
so much too kind of capitalize on what's
unique about the netflix you know bins
release format and um before we get too
far one primer spoilers are going to
about and to um if you're gonna sit down
to watch an episode of Bojack horseman
watch the whole watch the whole season
before you you do any extracurricular
stuff yeah um especially that first
season um so yeah when when Netflix look
like showed when Netflix gave out the
previews of that show for you know all
the news outlets and all the media
outlets to comment on review it they
only sent out the first six episodes oh
no no yeah and that's before that I mean
drop yeah that's before the drop that's
before for lack of a better word the
trap of this show was sprung it's hinted
at I mean it's definitely teased that in
cinta dad but it that show kind of like
the whole that show supper punches you
on in that first that first season well
yeah it's like you know cuz there are so
many shows that capitalize on that sort
of way oh you know haha like amusing
charming misanthrope you know like this
guy's kind of [ __ ] up but yeah like
he's alright but but it takes that idea
and then turns us in under a microscope
puts under a microscope weekend it turns
it on a deer and you know if Bojack
horseman was on Comedy Central or adult
swing it would probably be unbearable
because it's like you know if it was a
show like that on on Comedy Central it
usually Comedy Central it's like hey
yeah this uh this this misanthropic like
you know shucks three main character
who's a bastard to everyone who just
doesn't give a [ __ ] haha look at him
he's he's so wacky and zany says all the
rude stuff that you know you're not
allowed to say and that appeals to a
certain subset of human beings that I
never want to meet in my life um but
then the show actually goes back and
says oh yeah this is an extremely broken
human being yeah he's a horse but he's
extremely broken human being who
is going to die alone and miserable and
unloved if he does not fix his [ __ ] yeah
you know it takes the kind of character
we've seen so many a time and actually
you know forces it him to own up to his
[ __ ] yeah well and yeah I mean there was
a certain cuz it is edgy but I get what
you mean it's like it's an earned a
genius well yeah and it's like you know
I don't know adult swim adult swim in
comedy central they have different
brands but you cuz if this was on Comedy
Central I feel like there would be like
a lot more sex joke yeah and if this was
on adult swim I feel like there would be
a lot more adult swim's edginess has
sort of like a shrewd pneus about it
like it like it like you know it's a
little aggressive and it's edginess
sometime um and this has a nice sort of
middle ground stae yeah and I realize
like looking back on there's just so
many and you know what the animation
team on the show is like really
phenomenal t like it's very limited kind
of animation it's like flash puppeted
but like the team who's designing the
backgrounds and designing props and
everything that they cram so much
hilarious like gag stuff just into the
background and the writers even they
will cram so much just silly ass
wordplay like you'll just like have a
moment where there's a line works like
almost a college self-parody so we'll
just like say a line that fits within
the scene but it's worded specifically
in a way to kapil up to capitalize on
just like you know and just kind of make
this weird dr. Seuss passage like a
whole hip or Papalii yeah yeah the whole
hip of poeple is episode like but the
like so there's a scene where like for a
lot this is this is a line taken out of
context someone is trying to pitch an
article about a celebrity to give an
expose on a celebrity name Hank HIPAA
papalis he's a hippopotamus the show of
course you know half the characters or
more of than half the characters are
anthropomorphic animal people on and so
someone's trying to pitch to a magazine
hey I want an expose I want to do an
expose on Hank HIPAA papalis and the
editor-in-chief of magazine says
I'm going to try not to like trip over
this but it's like I'd love to take down
HIPAA papalis and topple the Acropolis
of monsters hypocrisy that in sconces us
it's like the lies is perfectly
delivered like it's completely straight
but you have to do a double take because
I cannot believe someone just like
belted out a dr. Seuss rhyme in the
middle of this conversation yeah it's
like several times throughout that
episode just any time somebody says Hank
HIPAA papalis it's immediately followed
by a very tight rhyme pattern that that
rhymes with him papalis like someone get
some someone who's defending Hank HIPAA
papalis on the news isn't road by the
anchor as a joining us now is a
hippopotamus apologist and arms or
sociologists that's right that that's
there that's their their chyron or their
calling well as he adds and and that's
that's an approach to writing just just
it from like a technical standpoint like
I always enjoy that when it's not just
it's not just like witty dialogue it's
also people having fun with the syntax
and having fun with and luckily it's
never obnoxious because you you can
never really see them coming yeah and
they're they're very in and out very
fast and they're not overplayed they do
catch you off guard so it's like the the
joke is earned it never gets obnoxious
unlike I've noticed to like especially
in the second season there there are
moments where even even in the middle of
comedic seed like without changing the
tone characters will just respond with
like a very succinct psychological
breakdown of something yeah and they
just leave the room it's like you know
they'll be having an argument over
something in a light way and then
someone will just hit the nail right on
the head and I can't think of a great
example but it's like you know you know
they'll be arguing on something shitty
Bojack didn't i'll just be like well
because you know my mother never loved
me blah blah blah because that and and
the scene will just continue and it's
like and you've just completely summed
up you've demystified the character and
just these little lines here just you
cracked open that can yeah it does
that's like every character yeah at some
point all them old like Princess
Carolyne to Amy Sedaris care throughs
like yo she's a she's an agent who does
not get any recognition or real
validation and there's a point where
she's you know trying to pull somebody
out of their own rut and they're saying
why are you helping me and Princess
Carolyne Amy Sedaris justice because my
life is a mess right now and I
compulsively take care of other people
when I don't know how to take care of
myself and the person she's trying to
pull out of the rut is just like oh I
thought you were gonna say because I
believe in you and then a mr. Jerse is
no i don't yeah yeah no it's just love
those little those little flourish is
there it's a the second is like it's
replacing what would have been a witty
quip that alludes to that with just the
nail on the head be and I like the
second season because you do feel a
progression from the first season the
first season like I said you know it's a
slow burn up to on the eleventh episode
of 12 and that first season until like
you know the hammer gets dropped and you
know the main character is just sort of
forced to recognize and it's been
building up and just this tension has
been building up and it's become more
and more apparent and then finally
episode 11 is you know Bojack goes on a
drug trip where he realizes he's a
horrible to dissatisfied person and all
that he's missed out on and that's like
episode 11 ad ends with him asking am i
a good person is it too late for me and
not getting an answer oh yeah you don't
get one um one in Yemen and pressing in
the season two and stuff like that it
seems like I don't know whether this was
the plan all along or just because we're
acclimated to it now but it's like it it
equal it seems to balance out you know
the whimsical antics with you know
breakthrough moments for characters
especially for Bojack because the other
number of episodes where scenes very
realistically will turn from amusing to
serious and real yeah you know like
season two is ok the trap is sprung and
now it's no not so much like when the
there is a bomb that goes off in season
11 and that bomb is not
our yes season episode 11 of season two
so it's like every so far both seasons
the eleventh episode of twelve always
has a bomb go off the bomb going off in
the eleventh episode of season one is a
realization the bomb going off in
episode 11 of season two is something
physical and real actually getting
destroyed oh it isn't it is a
relationship that goes nuclear DEFCON 10
like get into the bunker this isn't this
is not going to leave much like standing
in its weight yeah that one and and
correct me if I'm wrong but at that one
moment where she says you know it and if
you try to contact me or my family again
I would [ __ ] kill you with that was
that their one [ __ ] for those are one
[ __ ] for season two because that that
caught me way off guard like they they
dropping it's like so far interesting
patterns that are getting set one first
pattern is episode 11 of every season is
is going to just is going to wreck your
[ __ ] and and whenever a character says
like drops in that bomb whenever a
character says [ __ ] it is because Bo
Jack's relationship with in is Newt and
is not going to remember yeah oh that
yeah and that that episode man like it's
a cold escape from my way that episode
is paid first thank you wait that that
especially when you get to the second
half of that but episode it's you keep
hoping or at least I kept hoping it's
like you know you I'm still breaking out
of of you know the conventions of you
know like animated sitcom something i
don't know it's gonna be okay like it's
not gonna be what we expect no it's not
it's not gonna be okay he's not gonna be
okay put it in certain i've noticed that
a number of times this season where I
don't think you know be like it's not
going to be what I expected it to be and
then the show goes no it is what you
expected it to be it's there's no you
know there's no like morality parachute
these are your characters are you know
yeah it's um it's interesting
you know I was reading apparently a lot
of thought went into just like the very
intricate the very intricate decisions
of who was in what position in this um
yeah in the situation that kind of set
the bomb off in in s2f 11 um cuz you
know a lot of because I mean the whole
point of apparently the result so the
creator of the show is guiding Rafael
will ba blocksberg who I saw and was
terrified to actually say anything to in
public one time just because you just
saw him out without or was it at like a
place ah there was um was this oh
there's an epic on his horse stuff no
there's a there's an event in the LA
area called picture this where they team
up animators an artist with um stand-ups
and they did one that was a Bojack theme
where they had you know riders and well
not right it's more like comics who were
also voice actor jean Bojack on teaming
up with they get a whole lot of people
oh yeah like they were teaming up with
um they would even up with animators and
designers and storyboard artists from
the show when they were doing like you
know stand up sets were late was
character actress Margo Martindale there
no she I don't think she does stand-up
oh yeah so um zohair correct so there
was so there was this tickles me so hard
yes hey so there was this mote so you
know there's this event they you know
people from the show do their stand up
bits you know artists from the show draw
with the comics are talking about as
they're in the middle of their set and I
saw on the ground like oh my god there's
the creator and showrunner Raphael Bob
boksburg of a sketch group hug Old
English if anyone recalls that from the
early days of the internet comedy scene
and I was terrified to talk to him
because I was afraid that he was going
to stare deeply into my soul and see all
of my like lingering decrepid fermented
garden like darkness and gar vision who
I am as a human being is that that much
I mean you want the better people in it
yeah but I mean it would be more
terrified than you I mean if there's
somebody who's going to sniff it out i
believe it is this guy because he
knows he is perceptive enough to just
fill his goddamn horse cartoon with it
hey man I mean you know maybe you should
get your own animated series and then I
give your life's problems that sounds
like a great horrible idea yeah well I
mean it hurt so so um where was my
tangible I so Raphael boksburg is the
creator of the show and afraid to talk
uh yeah or fear of having him dissect
your soul and create a rolling back so
he apparently he's pitching the show to
tournant a the company that birthday
which is owned by former Disney big
stone man Michael Eisner bigwigs there
was there was this silly as [ __ ]
sketched I saw as well as SNL sketches
they put like at the end of the show
that's like so [ __ ] silly but for
some reason is very funny and it was
literally a sketch I think called big
wigs which was about corporate bigwigs
but who had these this giant hair thing
it was like Dean of an Amy Poehler just
within wig ridiculously enormous hair
and I just kept growing and they were
corporate bigwigs they kept like using
the phrase big wigs oh my god I'll dig
it up but then did the suits show up I
think they did is this it shows up to
show up oh my god and in the sharks I
don't know if I want that for a second
it's sequel to go so um what you I like
your shirt come in eric is eric is in
the booth eric is in the booth I am as
America's in the booth oh oh first time
we get a haircut oh yeah oh oh an
emergency erica was actually errigal in
the caution this was not planned this is
not playing nothing is planned all this
shouting by that I thought to myself oh
uh I was in the season finale yeah oh
[ __ ] that's right I was so you her the
cult ass improv team where are you level
six I was a level six Erica won a
contest to her than Todd yeah yeah
buzzing Erica won a contest to get like
drawn
as a background character in the the
season finale no no it was cool happy to
do it so Lord making art for the show
yeah yeah my head Udrih piece was great
is it did you did you have to submit a
piece of that how it works yeah and but
I already done that one like because of
the love in my heart for the show for
this sad cartoons it inspires yeah the
sad horse cartoon inspires me to indulge
in the guilty pleasure of the occasional
fan art its mission resident yeah as
they say did you you submitted the idea
the Bojack of the bar right yeah yeah
yeah the dream sequence it's based on
episode 11 of season one which is the
button yep then the Nutcracker of that
bed Susan and like like episode 11 of
this season oh yeah which was i watch
that this morning we did yeah did you
want to go back to bed yes yes and not
not crawl out I wanted to curl up and
and hurt forever and and then and then
not give a [ __ ] about anything and
cruise home on a time-lapse boat on a
boat on a truck on a boat on a truck
just just in the wreckage of the most
important things about yeah yeah I feel
like that's I mean the show actually
kind of knocks out the part with these
really cool kinda like visual metaphors
about that fo Jack's escape from LA is
this this you know this big ridiculous
stupid yacht that's being towed around
across the Mojave on a but on an
18-wheeler yeah so there's this kind of
image of like there's this motor she
Bojack riding on at the top of his boat
when did his main looking like you know
he's so majestic he's just going to [ __ ]
off to wherever but no he's actually
just he's getting climbing on the deck
of a boat that's being a holiday a giant
truck to go back to LA back to LA more
or less like you know there's nowhere
left to be
there's no escape wherever Bojack is
he's going to have to deal with him
being there so may as well may as well
be his is a horrible self in LA yeah but
no so rolling back um so there's this
interview where where mr. Bob boksburg
is talkin recounting his pitch session
to Michael Eisner and eyes are saying oh
yeah it's interesting that yeah this
this main character who you know he
comes up to that line of likeability but
you know it's like he's right up against
that line of likeability and Raphael is
like no he crosses the line of
likeability he becomes unlikable and
then he crosses back over it oh yeah i
mean that's that's you know sort of i
feel like the bread butter of that
character yeah those is the fact that
you give that's a realistic struggle i
mean i guess not everybody in the world
you know Flux is from likable to unlike
well but you know it's human beings do
yeah Evan flow upscale lapses and then
he kind of has to like rebuild a sense
of his decency after that the shows
aren't very similar but it's part of
what I've always appreciate or what I
have appreciated in my experience is
watching mad men there was like hey I
read where someone says hey if you're if
you're really jonesing for something to
replace the hole left by madmen being
over might I recommend this horse
cartoon yeah kind of cuz like this
that's like what they do with beau jack
is kind of like what they doing with
dawn in a sense yes they and I feel like
there it's similar that you get so much
backstory on who this person has been
used to be yeah cuz I mean it's like you
you need to see all every dimension of
this person how they got to being so in
such disrepair complete with like
pertinent occasional you know youth
views you know like flashbacks to the
youth yeah except you know Brandon's in
the Bulge actor yummy yeah Brandon who
plays jung da-jung yeah and with his
he's gonna drop a mixtape soon creepy
bouquet young Don shouts out to Brandon
how was he he seems
I've seen it means seems like a good
dude we were in the same improv troupe
as young and doesn't as Brandon who
plays young Draper speaking of improv
yeah there's a whole subplot there's a
subway that opens up in like the last
three ish episodes of the season where
it's parenting Scientology very clearly
but by instead of actually having the
character Aaron Paul character Todd gets
sucked into Scientology he gets sucked
into an improv class yeah I what I will
get right next to sign right next it's
right next door to the Scientology
Center which I feel is like kind of it's
interesting because like you see be one
of the name improv Peters is right
across the street from the celebrity
centre yeah but I mean it's like sign
the sign the churches I told you on so
many [ __ ] buildings in LA there's
bound to be an improv theater by wanna
bum well yeah half down yeah and I mean
comedy sportz used to be in that
building where you CBS app and um second
city used to be in the improv wasn't oh
did it I didn't know they moved yeah
I've only only where second city is now
is not where they were always Oh nomadic
comedians is roaming the land for a
place to spill their funny hunting for
caribou Xin yes anding and oh man I i
just love Todd tons of great characters
yes people you know there are lot of
similarities to be made to Jesse Pinkman
just by virtue him being kind of like a
slacker Lee sort of burnout stoner
character but Todd is very different
from Jesse he's so happy-go-lucky and
he's so he's so just kind of easygoing
he's kind of a screw-up he's desperate
for not desperate but he wants a sense
of purpose and he's very much a lost kid
even though he's 24 yeah but but he's
delicate yeah but he still eats just got
this Apple pneus and this happiness and
this is so good nagy yeah he's just
ridiculously good nature like no matter
what like Todd just taught his bow
Jack's only real friend who's still like
somehow sees the
in him yes like if there's anything you
can count on he's a sancho panza he's
just like he's the only like I feel like
as any as close as any character gets to
be completely reliably good-natured it's
like you know Todd needs to to figure
his life out and do something with
himself but he's the most benevolent
character yeah Todd screws up consistent
and suddenly ever hurts anybody
intentionally or accidentally except
when he gets that pair oh yeah that pen
yeah he's that's right this whole pen
thing I'm up anything oh my god which is
like I was trying to figure out cuz you
know I mean you start to pick up on you
know okay not always gonna do what I
think they're gonna do so like you know
this isn't gonna become one of those
things where they're both just trying to
get the pen so hard the neither of them
gets it cuz they're both being petty
it's like the logical conclusion happens
you know she gets that pen but the way
Todd weasels it I was not expecting
either yeah and then there was the How I
Met Your Mother like fake outs yes okay
so there's a yeah let's take some
mistakes i'm talking back there is an
episode where Princess Carolyne DEA
agent um finds JD Salinger is paid to
said look voiced by alan arkin
brilliantly yes and she gets JD Salinger
to come to Hollywood by pitching to him
listen I wanted cypher you to come back
and I know a place where people hate
reading so much they will hire other
people to read for them and not pay them
a living wage and all those people doing
the reading all they want to do is write
things that one day other people will
never read like making fun of the whole
like the industry of readers doing
coverage in Hollywood a JD Salinger's so
gaga or he's so excited to finally go
someplace where people will not hound
him about catcher in the rye ever again
he goes to hollywood he sits down with
the with them a network exec played by
Lisa Kudrow who's currently dating
Bojack at this point in the series have
any pitches his show idea celebrity or
Hollywood stars ok so the D from the
Hollywood sign gets stolen in the in the
first season never replace Oh Hollywood
is really was renamed Hollywood for the
rest
the show what and and free for this
version of hallowed probably the real to
hollywoo is yeah is a proposed yeah it's
like a version of Hollywood that's a
little exaggerated a little more
ridiculous I'm a Ryan Seacrest yes and
I'm I don't know Emily's you something
yeah some lady is out today yeah
somebody got kid that um that's an
Access Hollywood type show so JD
Salinger pitches a celebrity game show
called Hollywood stars and celebrities
what do they know do they know things
let's find out find out and the way
which alan arkin delivers that title is
so incredible um do they stick with it
multiple episodes reference the show
like I complete name yet literally want
you to know that name yeah hitters there
is an episode that takes place during a
taping of the first episode of that show
and I was not I was not expecting the
Daniel Radcliffe bit yeah Daniel
Radcliffe is the surprise contestant
which is awesome boys by Daniel
Radcliffe ways by Dave I love the way
love goes talents oh yeah and I love
their animation of your his face just
that weird like angular face they get
him I think now I happen to see like an
early and early design of Todd at one
point hush-hush I won't tell you how but
I feel like do Daniel Redknapp Raphael
Bob wat skins I would never do that I
would never know how I would like I cuz
i would i would probably kidnap him and
then he would be in my kidnap room is he
in the cooler that we are currently
recording on top I doubt it okay like
roughly Bravo Bob Walker would be in my
kidnap room and then you would tell me
everything wrong with who I am as a
human being that made me want to kidnap
him and I would just kind of crumpled
into tears yeah um no so I feel like the
Daniel Radcliffe designed as a little
has like some similarities to an early
design of Todd because apparently it
took a while for Todd to todds designed
to get nailed down I love Todd's design
Todd's design is great he has that like
one light will count Preston chic and
he's the president Jake and liked a
little bundle teeth yeah he looks a
little bit just kind of unsure about
everything so
so um where was I going ok so JD
Salinger is now the showrunner for this
game show and Todd ends up hanging out
in the control booth and fighting with
this like hot shot up and coming like
assistant on the show for JD Salinger's
pen just like whoever whoever just like
distinguishes themselves during the
production of this first episode when JD
Salinger's pen which he used not to
write that's what I captured the rise
but like raise high the roof beeps
carpenter oh my and it's like Todd
weasels his way into getting that pen
after it Barry after he screws up a
bunch and it very clearly ends up going
to the hotshot assistant who's way more
qualified but through his Todd foolery
yeah top goes on it looks like really
morose and the the hotshot um the
hotshot assistant ends up giving the
pentatonic maybe all you knew something
for to believe in you and that was
Todd's like gambit play he was faking
being morose so he would win the pen and
shove it in her face and it's it's great
and I chuckled I did too I was not
expecting it to go down quite that way
yeah well he has that whole episode with
the chickens here yeah there's a whole
with Ron Funches and Ron Funches is a
couple people run Funches is I think
he's the what's the other chicken a
chain called general farms he's the
gentle farms farmer he's as a general
farms armor or the maybe he's the
general fund farmer and the voiceover
for the chicken four days I took her
four days yeah he's a few characters and
and then there's the meow meow fuzzy
face was I that's actually a suitable
yarbrough yes since we don't I 1091 yet
which he does not sound like he's Reno
911 character even though they're both
cops oh no and I and the way they did
took it I didn't even realize it at
first but I love the way they they keep
doing the whole like you know kind of
handheld like zoo me lad episode every
time they come to the cops when they're
just trying to figure out if he's a
loose can yeah we got which like
old-timey cop cop action movie lingo
defines him oh yeah but but yeah it's
that of the chicken or days at is the
chicken the chickens episode of of this
season kind of exists just to explain
how meat works in this universe or
animals are people so light it's
actually terrifying and dystopian yeah
it's like the chickens that are that are
used for you know poultry meat are just
are genetically engineered to be you
know horribly stunted and like a hormone
addled brain dead prisoners yeah and and
just because Todd doesn't know what to
do he ends up he ends up protect
harboring a fugitive free chicken yet
voiced by the the lead designer of the
show Lisa Hanawalt and and odd they
really get a lot of that chicken speak
ya book back ya know Lisa animal I was
very I was like amazed to find out Lisa
Hanna what was the voice of the fugitive
chicken who ends up getting named becca
becca because she she does the buck-buck
very [ __ ] well and very committed Oh
totally yeah I'm always I'm always
excited when when people will put you
know a good deal you know like an
appropriate amount of effort into just
making chicken sounds yeah but I I can't
help but be like so amazed at anyone
that can really sell a Donald Duck
impression hey those those people are
like superheroes to me it's like that's
a power I wish I had but I really that's
a great episode Lisa's to me as far as
Todd is concerned cuz that is kind of
the Todd episode yeah a lot of its hot
episode there's a Diane episode there's
kind of a Princess Carolyne episode
there was a Princess Carolyne episode
last season there's a brisk air because
there's a prominent storyline then pops
up on a couple with her yeah and there's
um there's a good strong mr. peanut
butter through line throughout the
series throughout the the season Paula
paul f tompkins use a is a easy pool
chap guys can call up he's got a
mustache he does and a nice suits does
have hella suits you know um God yeah
it's kind of like the tot episode the
chickens one and I just I just so
appreciate that moment in the barn where
they're being like shot at yeah and he
just kind of sums up what it feels like
to be in your 20 in your 20s yes I come
was he what you see say I don't know why
I keep getting into my situations these
are these messes I I feel like my life
is just a series of loosely connected
wacky misadventures and just using yeah
you can 20 something that's kind of how
I feel generally yeah likewise although
I don't think either of us have ever
made our own Disneyland somehow Annie
and I so love that whoa I can't remember
exactly the situation is but somebody is
showing pictures and like an unrelated
is it maybe it's um maybe it's in the
eleventh episode there's there he's
looking at pictures and one of them is
of them at todd has the hots did yet the
eleventh episode yeah just is this it's
quick but this season is wait I mean
it's almost like this season is so much
more competent in the first season
naturally because the first season just
kind of had to set up what the show is
about and a general not general but a
specific direction of where it's headed
and this season built up on that it's
like it's weirder it's it's funnier it's
more it's more specifically directly
funnier when things get dark they get
really dark when things get bad and and
downcast they go all out yeah it seems
like they're they're really free to to
it's like if you look at the first
season it almost feels like it feels
natural because you have the first half
words you know the status quo of boat
Jax life and all the other characters
around him and then you know the season
ends with him making a big realization
the season ends with his status quo has
been rocked slowly but surely but it's
been broken down to that point words
like okay something has got to [ __ ]
give now and then season two it's like
we pick up and it's
like okay now we know that this guy is
at least trying to address his problems
and work on himself someone you know and
that becomes a prominent like this is
you know as it is season two of the show
it's also kind of a new phase in that
character's life you know in BO Jack's
life so you know those those poignant
moments and the scenes where they you
know actually do call out some real
relationship dynamics and some real you
know you know poised like you know
poisonous behaviors and stuff like that
those those come more not frequently but
they're kind of interspersed throughout
you know there are poignant moments sit
around then you can see their their
evolution way more specifically and kind
of chart them and see that things are
they're building up and moving along